ce matin sur la ligne 34 sainte
catherine dans hochelaga toutes les
conditions sont bonnes
votre travaux pas de trafic ait pas trop
de clients
pourtant chantal rouillard la chauffeuse
est déjà en retard
présentement je serai supposé déjà est
rendu à la station pignons de pin à
leurs 13 en avoir 17
je suis actuellement à parthenay de
maison que je devais ici en avril 10
arrivés au bout de la ligne
chantal doit vite repartir dans l'autre
sens pour limiter son retard
voyez le supposé de des parties déjà
depuis 4000 ans j'ai pas encore fait mon
embarquement
donc j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller à la
toilette non une des difficultés
récentes des chauffeurs ce sont les
limites de vitesse qui ont été abaissées
à 30 dans plusieurs secteurs il faudrait
continuer à rouler à 40 45 50 pour
pouvoir y arriver
moi mon intention c'est poisson c'était
de conserver mon cas nous qu'on ne veut
pas voir de le contrat l'ancien alors à
cette heure-ci la stm donne 24 minutes à
ses chauffeurs pour aller de la station
papineau à la station viau on va faire
le trajet en voiture on va respecter les
limites on va s'arrêter à chaque fois
qu'il faut s'arrêter et on va voir
combien de temps ça nombreux
[Musique]
oui
il
[Musique]
alors voilà ça nous a pris un peu plus
de 16 minutes pour faire le parcours ça
veut dire qu'il reste huit minutes aux
chauffeurs pour déposer et prendre des
passagers sur 30 arrêts entre la station
papineau et la station bio plusieurs
chauffeurs nous ont confié dépassé les
limites de vitesse pour pouvoir arriver
à leurs fins d'auditionner les maires
mais arrivent alors les salles arrive
pour aux facteurs nous sommes allés
vérifier de façon aléatoire et nous
avons constaté plusieurs excès de
vitesse importants sur certaines lignes
alors regardez là on est dans une zone
de 30 kilomètres avec le syndicat des
chauffeurs affirme que ses membres sont
de plus en plus souvent victimes de
plaintes de clients parfois agressive je
ne suis pas pour l'excès de vitesse
par contre je peux comprendre exactement
pourquoi un chauffeur d'autobus vaut
rouler un peu plus vite que la limite
permise
des retards sur les horaires c'est si
les clients qui a acquis en h'cup
directement son temps pour les écoles
sont à temps pour le travail
c'est le chauffeur de thériault ce
qu'ils espéraient avec sow et c'est
normal que le client est insatisfait
aujourd'hui en 2018 la stm affirme avoir
augmenté les tomes parcours ces
dernières années et les réajuster tous
les 18 mois
ce qu'on a mis aussi en place ce qu'on
appelle les temps de battement
ce sont des petites périodes à la fin
des parcours qui permettent aux
chauffeurs soi que quand ils arrivent en
avance parce que ça peut arriver
ou qu'ils arrivent en retard ce qu'on
comprend aussi va pouvoir se
repositionner au bon moment pour
reprendre son trajet et reprendre le
parcours de manière correcte et en
respect avec les aurait là dessus la stm
promet une révision complète du réseau
cet automne en attendant le sujet des
horaires est au coeur des négociations
de convention collective en ce moment
entre les chauffeurs et la société
transports
les syndicats n'excluent pas de
déclencher une grève ici thomas gerber
radio-canada mourir